It's great to welcome to the program today,
Tom rivet Karnak who is coauthor of the book
future.
We choose surviving the climate crisis.
Tom's also a leader in the fields of international
diplomacy, energy policy and climate change.
Three areas, Tom, that are relevant.
If you're going to be involved in the negotiation
of the Paris climate Accords, which you you
ended up participating in.
How did that even come about?
I did.
Well, it was, it was a great privilege to
be so closely involved in the Paris climate
Accords.
I was actually working in New York where I
am right now when I was working at an NGO
called CDP, where I was helping companies
identify the types of strategies that would
make them more effective, um, to deal with
the climate crisis.
And in that position, uh, through a friend,
I got to meet Christiana Figueres, who's my
co author on this book and at the time was
the executive secretary of the UN climate
convention.
And we spent a day together in New York around,
and what was clear was that she was obviously
surrounded by many brilliant people inside
the UN, but there tends to be the emergence
of not group think might be a little unfair,
but sort of the same solutions to the same
problems that you've been struggling with
for a long time.
And she knew that she wanted somebody in there
who could think about the political challenges
in a new way.
And so that's why she hired me to come and
run the political strategy a few years before
Paris.
So one of the common, I guess, refrains that
I hear from people who take as seriously as
we should be, the, the issue of climate change
about the Paris, uh, um, uh, accord is that
the final result feels sort of underwhelming.
In other words, all of this negotiation just
to say, well, we'll commit to limit the increase
of temperature above pre-industrial levels.
Can you talk a little bit about what the negotiation
is actually like and, and why?
Just looking at the outcome ignores a lot
of what goes into even doing this in the first
place.
Sure.
No, I can definitely talk about that.
And, and but one contextualize in comment
because you're absolutely right.
And what you said is, is negotiations and
outcomes are pathways and that only meaningful
if they're followed.
That's where, that's interesting.
So for many years the negotiations had been
mired in this issue of fairness, right?
So developing countries said to develop countries,
you caused this problem.
And what's more, you said you'd sought it
out in 1991 when the UN first started thinking
about this.
So go away and do something meaningful about
it.
And then come back and we'll talk about a
global agreement.
Whereas the developed countries would say,
well, the world is different now.
Many of the emissions actually come from developing
countries, India, China, many other places
are developing very rapidly.
This now needs to be an everyone everywhere
type of an endeavor.
And the challenges that both of those perspectives
were correct.
Right?
And both of them were justified and very defensible.
So for a long time, the discussion in the
climate negotiations was about, well, whose
responsibility is this?
And it became mired in this sort of zero sum
mentality of this was a burden that nobody
wanted to take on.
And everybody was trying to pass around between
each other.
One of the things I think we did in Paris,
or at least we took serious steps towards
doing, although it's unfinished business,
is we flipped that, you know, dealing with
the climate crisis is of course an urgent
challenge.
It is also the biggest economic opportunity.
It's the biggest opportunity to improve the
quality of our lives.
It's the biggest opportunity to improve our
biodiversity, our, our, our quality of air,
et cetera, et cetera.
And we started to think about it more around
less as a burden to be shared and more of
an opportunity to be captured.
So that changed the nature of the negotiations
to a degree where every country would agree
collectively we need to solve this in the
long term and for the next few years I'll
put down my, as to what I'll do for the next
few years.
That's consistent with my politics that is
of benefit to me as a country.
And that enabled the spirit to begin to change,
which was the real breakthrough we needed.
So there's a whole range of estimates that
are made about what might the planet look
like in five 10 30 et cetera, years.
There's not wholesale agreement, although
there are straight out bad faith actors and
then there are just sort of like reasonable
disagreements within the the the communities
that are appropriately dealing with this in
good faith.
In the book you outline, you know, a possible
scenario where we just fail to deal with this
issue and what 2050 might look like in that
scenario.
And then you also talk about moving in the
direction by 2050 of carbon neutrality, regenerated
economies and Regina, you know, moving in
the right direction so to speak, is part of
the problem on this that even for people who
believe the science, it's sort of difficult
to really believe that nightmare scenario
because it seems so horrifying and that may
cause some sort of paralysis and actually
getting going on it.
Yeah, I think that's a great point.
And I think that there has been this massive
discrepancy between the world we see around
us, which until recently has largely carried
on as we've more or less known it.
And these sort of very challenging, very alarming
predictions of periods of time that are just
a few decades in the future.
And I think for many people it can be difficult
to bring those two things together, particularly
when the solutions that are proposed seem
small, right?
They seem like small iterations on your life.
Sadly, it's becoming more and more possible
to imagine what that negative future might
look like.
Right?
I mean just in the last few months, if we
look at the terrible devastation of the wildfires
in Australia and the unbelievable loss of
life and property and the heartbreaking loss
of biodiversity, we look at the, you know,
the disappearance of coral reefs around the
world.
We look at the warming of the oceans and the
hotspots.
We look at the burning of the Amazon and of
Siberia and of California, the floods in England,
the melting of Antarctica.
Unfortunately we are getting sharper relief
of what it could be like.
And these early signs should wake us up because
science tells us we still have time, right?
This decade I would argue, will end up being
the most consequential decade in the history
of humanity.
Now, that's a lot for us to take on board,
but we have to face that and we have to face
it now if we're going to have the kind of
impact that we need to have to improve the
world in the way that we still can.
So on the personal versus structural, we've
talked before about how, you know, putting
a disproportionate focus on plastic straws
distorts the reality that a vast majority,
what we have to deal with is actually the
output in waste from large corporations, particularly
in certain industries that are the, the, the
disproportionate contributors.
So if you talk about plastic straws and making
sure that you're sorting your cardboard boxes
the right way, that it unfairly puts the burden
on individuals when in reality that's not
where, where the burden is.
Can you talk a little bit about that, because
it seems, I mean from the book it seems as
though you say that there needs to be structural
action, but individual action is also important.
Sure.
So, um, so in the book we, you know, we set
out what needs to happen in order to get us
on this trajectory to create a future that
we still can.
Right.
And as you say, that's a variety of actions
that we can all participate in.
Now there's three types of actions we talk
about.
One of those is actually who we are as human
beings.
Living through this fundamental transformation
is not easy for us to embrace that.
And we talk about how we can dig into some
of the deeper elements of the human psychology
to prepare ourselves for that and to be positive
actors for a great future.
The second thing we talk about is our own
activities.
So it is true that we are economic actors,
where political actors are, we're citizens,
we're consumers, we're parents, we're employees,
we're teachers, whatever we are.
And in all of those roles, there's a huge
amount that we can do to create a positive
future.
And it's very meaningful, right?
Everyday counts.
Now whether that changing your diet, whether
it's changing the way you move, change and
the way you heat your home, et cetera, or
re-imagining your role in the world so that
you can actually do something that has a more
positive impact or less of a negative impact.
And that's really important right here.
Individuals have a major role in pushing systems
to actually reach tipping points.
But we also say, and this is the third category
of action that we outlined in the book, you
know, we need to use the power that we have
in relation to national governments in relation
to corporations, in relation to regional governments
and state governments to push them to participate
in civil disobedience, vote in a way that
is consistent with the kind of future we want
to create this.
We've left this so late that we can no longer
say it's the responsibility of business or
investors or governments or individuals.
This has to be an everyone everywhere type
of initiative.
And I think the problem with that dialogue
of where does responsibility lie is it can
be cyclical, right?
You know, one time it's fashionable to say
it's individuals, another time it's fashionable
to say it's governments.
The truth is it's everyone and it's urgent
and we need to be on this now.
Yeah, I mean it seems that in a way it's sure
it can be about recycling and plastic straws
and maybe looking at an electric car or something
like that.
But at the same time, it's about the ability
of a population to at a certain point say,
unless you're seriously going to deal with
this, we don't vote you into office.
Right, exactly.
Or more than that.
You know, we go out on the streets and we
shut down operations until, you know, the
first duty of a democratic government is to
its population.
By that metric, most governments in the West
are failing their most fundamental responsibility.
Some are failing reasonably badly, some are
failing really badly.
Um, and some are doing a reasonably good job.
We've been speaking with Tom rivet Karnak
who is co author of the book the future.
We choose surviving the climate crisis.
Also the podcast outrage
and optimism, which you should absolutely
check out.
Tom, thanks again for your time.
I so appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Great to be here.